we are a nation of migrants
there's hardly
hardly probably
anybody that lives in the UK that doesn't originally
come from somebody who migrated here
uh we absolutely should open our doors
and people keep going on about
there was mentions about all
if they're illegal
that I heard somebody on the news yesterday said
but if they're illegal
we've got to put them somewhere
they're not illegal
they are migrants from somewhere
I mean what would people feel
I'm a teacher
I have to speak to my kids about this I say
how would you feel if something suddenly happened here
really suddenly
you didn't expect a war
something and we wanted
and we had to send our children somewhere
we had to flee somewhere
wouldn't we expect to be seen with open arms
you know and for me
I think it's a it's um
we should be embarrassed about it
I think it's an atrocity
do you make a Suella Braveman
using language like invasion
or Leanderson
the deputy chair of the Tory party
possibly record or print what I would say about her